hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for another special edition of
the Monday morning podcast if you knew
in my podcast you probably think what's
a special what's a special one usually
I'm here by myself
laying in my [ __ ] underwear running
my Yap but every once a while I have a
special guest and this this person will
not let you down this is one of my great
friends in this business is one of the
funniest bastards I ever met in my life
he has a new special coming out on
Netflix called mouth full of shame
that's already funny on March 14th
please welcome the legendary Jim Norton
thank you Bill that's a nice intro I
don't know how to handle nice things
being said about me I know does it make
you uncomfortable that's why I was going
as big as I could go I was feeling you
squirming one of my great friends one of
the best comics I ever saw just listen
just watching you squirm over there I
can handle personal things that you hate
far away we are from one another it is
odd my managers kind of seen their
uncomfortably this [ __ ] giant [ __ ]
bulge in the middle it looks like a
retired figure skater sorry alright
anyways I can handle personal like cuz
we are great friends but any type of
compliments of work I can't it makes me
so like you like watching clips of
yourself I'm gonna torture you for this
ah drives me nuts dude
I watched it we gotta watch a clip of
yourself when they bring you back and
then the people in the room like oh yeah
that was good it's so [ __ ] cold
if you ever do a talk show and then I'm
like and they play either something
you've already done or whatever you're
promoting I literally will you know if
they cut to it and I actually look to
monitors see if the crowds watching it
at home and then I just literally I'll
put my fingers in my ears if I have to
I'll start humming no humiliating oh
it's right do it man I can't watch can
they feel like they're fake laugh and
like they don't really like it they're
just playing along to be polite I feel
like that like they're just kind of
being nice to little jimmy nort and
they're just being polite to me the only
way I can watch myself as if um I filmed
myself at a club and I'm just watching
it but the second that I would write if
I knew it was gonna be uploaded or
broadcasted and I know that everybody's
gonna see it immediately I'm like oh my
god why don't I do that with my hand
what did this [ __ ] say everything
just immediately it's horrific but
having said that I actually made sure
mine last special
that I sat through it I sat through a
couple of times to make sure that at
least I had like the look of it the look
of it right now did you do that with
your new special mouthful of shame that
comes out on March 4th it's funny yeah I
did an obsessive I probably seen it
about 60 times but just in editing like
I don't mind watching it to edit like I
go point by point over both shows I want
I know exactly what I want from the Late
Show Pulis from the Early Show I'm
really anal about it that's good that's
good to have yeah cause I don't trust
that like anyone M flicks is easier
because there's no commercials you have
to worry about and they don't give a
[ __ ] if it's 56 minutes for promos it
can be an hour to hour and three so I
was very comfortable doing that but like
you said as soon as somebody else is in
the room I want to hang myself but I can
do it alone all day cuz I know I'm doing
it as part of it's still part of the
work but once that's done I'm like I can
never watch it again I walk out of the
room people watch it oh hey can I see
that thing absolutely and then they sit
down and I close the door and walk out
could you watch it with me could you
watch it with someone you're really
really close to if like it's not like
somebody you need to impress it I would
have to be standing up I would be
standing up with my [ __ ] hands on top
of my head like that like is it suck be
doing that the whole time and she
literally gets mad going shut she knows
at this point Nia knows to be like you
know she'll just come up say hey I
watched your special it was good or I
watched this it was good and blah blah
and I go okay good well you start like
if some parts coming up that you don't
like where you go I hated the way I did
this thing like right before it happens
cuz you're like you don't want them to
watch it and pretend to like it when you
know it's not it's [ __ ] sick I have
that thought once it comes out like this
I just I just go just a noise I just
yell over over and it just it will
bother her but I've also learned that
yeah just that you're gonna think it's
way way worse than it [ __ ] is but
don't you find the comedians who are so
comfortable watching themselves saw
something wrong with that yeah man I
can't I keep your eye back could
literally watch a [ __ ] marathon of
their entire career yeah oh yeah I love
that sport coat I loved when I wore that
the way I've rolled those sleeves up by
absolutely this was a dog and cat thing
you don't live in loop I've got a loop a
tear watching Robert Klein videos
because I we are having him coming in
and he's one of my idols
and I'm watching like Robert Klein from
The Tonight Show in 81 82 83 watch him
on 74 on Soul Train or whatever he was
[ __ ] great man yeah Robert Kline's a
guy that most people don't mention like
no one talks about Robert Klein anymore
as much as I mentioned prior and Karl it
and the Robert Klein is the most
underrated guy I think Seinfeld always
gives him a bunch of props and was
talking like how he he was that I think
that was one of his guys he liked Cosby
and Robert Klein I believe right and I
forget how he put it but he was like
sort of their age like when he was doing
those things in the 70s and he was going
to colleges like he was like that age
part of that generation so he was kind
of theirs right thank keep like Carlin
was more of a 60s guy even though he
blew up in the 70s I think people from
that generation remember him but it's
weird how some people despite their
contributions will kind of slip through
the cracks like that right it's I find
with most people that when that are like
that they're not into self-promotion so
if you're not spoon-feeding it like the
amount of [ __ ] journalists out there
if you just tell them you know like I'm
one of the edgiest guys on the set but
not that's to me to straight but if
you're you're like the I would always
like I don't know I would I would equate
it to Detroit that calls itself
Hockeytown like they gave themself a
[ __ ] nickname yeah like why are you
hockey town wouldn't it at least be
montreal montreal canadiens they have
the most [ __ ] you know championships
they got the fans would literally drive
people out of town I mean why cuz you're
that well no one's action the King of
Pop not saying he wasn't good but he
kind of gave himself that like right
that nickname but like how a lot of
hacks do that and nobody thinks that
somebody would be a big enough [ __ ]
to give themselves a nickname so people
just kind of go with it like people must
have called him the King of Pop cuz
nobody could be that [ __ ] a
narcissistic to give himself the
nickname the King of Pop because we did
and the press loves them because they
write the story for them why they'll
love a Rex Ryan but hate Bill Belichick
like Belichick is smart enough to be
like you [ __ ] are gonna take any little
thing that I say and turn it into
bulletin board right here oh that's why
he stands icon you know they're good and
I think next week's gonna be a tough
game and just taking only good time and
then they want a guy like Rex Ryan gonna
go gonna win the soup
oh yeah then they love him I didn't come
here to kiss the Rings I'm gonna go in
there we're gonna shove it right up
their ass and then just like before he's
done talking their article is written
yeah you want to go four and twelve yeah
I love Rex Ryan I love what a priority
is I love it that he loves his wife's
feet he's the best what he loves his
wife too yeah his wife keeps him on the
rails I swear to God if he didn't have
that guy would ate himself to death I
see it like all that [ __ ] talk and he
does you see like that's why I love that
guy when I watch him like he's used his
flaws I'm like oh my god this guy he's a
[ __ ] show
this guy's a [ __ ] show and he loves his
wife to death because she saved him you
totally see the whole thing yeah he's a
disaster a disaster
yeah yeah but he is but there was
something endearing about that not you
know I just started watching football
again dude I can't care about it I love
you the biggest when we were coming up
you were huge camel Cowboys fan and then
you were huge Yankee fan yeah I just I
stopped I start going on the road more
and more I just stopped caring as much
I'm like I'm putting in so much effort
to these guys and then I meet them and
they don't give a [ __ ] that I'm alive I
had a couple of bad experiences with
athletes
I remember done yeah I was wrong about
the Jeter thing I was a baby I really
act like a little douchebag I was
[ __ ] he was a dick to not time I
think but I weigh overreacted on the
year I'm embarrassed by that well if you
if you if you go to the psychology of
the way you overreacted it wasn't really
just your love for the guys and the team
yes you are a jilted lovers Patrice used
to always say yeah absolute lover that's
exactly what it is I mean you know the
the husband that becomes the stalker is
the guy that was obsessed with his wife
like you know that's what I was I was
obsessed with him and they didn't love
me more my biggest meltdowns was gene
Simmons because he hurt my feelings he
blew me off when I wanted a photo and he
was kind of a dick about it and I just
ruined me I [ __ ] I killed him on the
radio about it and I kind of felt bad
because he was nice to me the next time
I saw him I met him one time he was
teasing me about losing my hair and [ __ ]
I just so wanted to be like do do you
think if anybody's buying that [ __ ]
Darth Vader oh yeah you're wearing a
walk in your [ __ ] head that's
terrible yes Chewbacca's hair like dude
it is like shoe polish black I mean you
can't you talk to the guy and you just
can't not even look it but what I love
about him is he would sit here and laugh
along with you and not give a [ __ ] and
then just scribble down
Chewbacca with hair and the next day
there'd be a picture of him dressed as
Chewbacca his [ __ ] written on it and he
would make a million dollars I'll
unapologetically go make a million
dollars off of this he really doesn't
care the only thing I like about genome
this is one thing that Dan Rather
interviewed him and he talked about is
he's a patriotic guy like nobody loves
America more than gene Simmons cuz his
mother was in a concentration camp and
she came here and when he was a kid and
he remembers I did I think he was
Iranian I'm the biggest kiss fan yeah I
know you're way off far off yeah he was
easy
Brazilian I thought he was Irish yeah
he's ah he's uh he was born in his name
is really miss hime White's I think he
was born in Israel and he says his
mother's dig hi old when she came to
Ellis Island and he tells that story to
Dan Rather about how moving it was to
have them tell her to put her armed so
you watch that and it's like that's the
gene he should be showing people wait
what did she do that because she was she
didn't know any better she came to
America and and she had to pledge
allegiance to America to get in that's
what you did so she's a hile Dan the guy
put his putting her arm downs like no no
you don't have to do that so if that
made Jean a incredible patriot those
people were so lucky back then that
there was no YouTube oh that would have
ruined her life run for office never
even open up bakery yeah the Sikh high a
little girl is now coming of age yes
make some pastries [ __ ] you you hit
little of it [ __ ] yeah all of that yeah
picture hurt the statue behind it yeah
you're right
there's no livin it down now do you have
any clips about you I think there's so
many things on me that could ruin my
life that III think that it's almost
there's so many that they can't at this
point things I've said or you know
things I've admitted the things you know
I think like [ __ ] I wish I didn't talk
about that way back when so I didn't
realize that it could want me or do you
not care yeah I mean I just I mean it's
kind of hat it's inevitably gonna happen
to everybody they're gonna go like oh
you said this in 2006 okay oh did I yeah
all right well why don't you get in your
time machine and have me apologize the
2006 version of me yeah you know what a
lot of it is is I would equate it to the
the Eddie Murphy thing where Eddie
Murphy put out delirious and he did all
that that material about Gabe
people and everybody laughed and nobody
said [ __ ] I'm sure gay people didn't but
mainstream did not and then when
mainstream catches up and starts to
learn that oh that's really you know
hurtful and bla bla bla bla bla to gape
then all of a sudden he's just like you
know they talk oh my god they look the
other way Bob you know when you when
they talk about that part of the special
they act it's like well where were you
during that right I know you saw it you
sat there and left it the same way I did
I didn't I didn't know that I don't know
what that it was to that level so I
think you can do that with anybody well
I think what let's any off the hook
especially with that type of material is
the whole lot you know I was giving her
a ride excuse for that special young
lady boy if that didn't make me love
Eddie nothing will but like you after
that you're like yeah all right we get
it we get I don't know good for him who
knows I don't get involved in people's
personal lives I don't give up I don't
either
in not in a judgmental way I love the
fact when when things about let's say
any celebrity come out they could or
could not be true it makes me like them
more like it makes me understand yeah
this this is a public persona like I
feel bad for there's one major actor in
particular who must now a massage
therapist said he was doing stuff and I
feel so bad for this guy I'm like he
said what a torture it is to live your
life being afraid you're gonna get
caught alpha beta who you are yes yeah
oh no but god that's gotta be you no
effect how much money you make because
yeah that's all it's also there you know
something a lot of that personal life
[ __ ] that kind of drove me away from
ESPN because it used to just be the
games and they'd show highlights and
just seem like a bunch of people you
know broadcasting that just loves sports
but when they started to just keep like
delving into these people's lives and
trying to like do like the controversy
[ __ ] I just um I don't know I just kind
of got away from it after a while that's
why I love the sports packages I just
taped the games that I want to watch I
blow through the pregame and I never
watch any post game analysis or anything
I just watched the [ __ ] game and
that's it and that's it you know the
Knicks recently my Hannibal Hannibal
Buress retreated this thing where they
did the first half with you went to the
game and there wasn't a bunch of people
running around shooting t-shirts at ya
every time it was a stop at you play not
a bunch of music playing and I would
have loved to have gone to that
yeah it is distracting and they think we
need constant stimulation and constant
noise like no we're at the game I I'm
okay just watching the game I'm okay if
it's the third inning and it's a you
know two and one and there's one
I don't need [ __ ] manic stop it
basketball is the worst basketball is
the worst just because they run out into
the court it could be like a really
critical part of the game 103 103 time
out there's like time for like one more
shot these [ __ ] [ __ ] guy comes
out of gorilla suit t-shirts at you and
[ __ ] and it's just kind of it becomes
like a Chucky Cheese you supposed to be
teaching your kid the game here like
this is really important and there's all
these people with that extra excited
look on their faces they're holding the
t-shirt uh-huh I always I sit through
all of that hoping that I'm gonna you
know nobody ever sits with me but I have
this this is my little [ __ ] dream is
that I'll sit and everyone else would
just stared [ __ ] daggers at them and
they won't do it anymore
I don't give a [ __ ] about a bunch of
[ __ ] my jumping off a trampolines
dunking the ball it's actually
embarrassing to white people like look
how little we can jump it's humanly I
need this here I saw that at a son's
game I had a great time at the game but
that [ __ ] they're like here they
come look crazy trampoline [ __ ] guys
and it's like [ __ ] nine white guys
coming out there we don't need him
nastic s-- again there's nobody blocking
him either and there's mats at all it's
like a nerf hoop like taken to the next
level I'm sure someone's gonna tweet me
actually that's really hard combining
those sports but um well I hate mascots
I think they're unnecessary
and they're stupid and they they they
child up the game like that I I we
interviewed the Philly Phanatic
in 2001 I like the Philly Phanatic I
smells those uniforms stink I try
remember about being next to the Philly
fan aight the stench I'm sure they all
smell like that but there were some fur
[ __ ] out it's horrendous and to me
they just they do nothing to make me
enjoy the game that's what I kind of
always liked about like I hated the Mets
his [ __ ] mr. met and that big stupid
I love my lack of imagination of that
one it's just a guy with a baseball for
a head yeah mister and then they named
him after the team only his stupid
was the first idea what are you gonna
about mr. met good he's got a baseball
head he's a guide so we'll call a mister
we play during Valentine's Day maybe we
could have mrs. met I actually love a
mascot standing on a street corner
holding up a tax tax thing and doing a
stupid dance when I'm sitting at a red
light it makes me laugh my [ __ ] ass
off I don't know what it is I think they
should have them just mascots should be
like in traffic like every 200 yards is
just somebody doing a stupid dance just
to entertain you that's when I need
entertainment not when I'm [ __ ] at an
entertainment thing I don't need
entertainment during the entertainment
in between the moments of entertainment
you don't need extra entertainment yeah
and it's not even entertaining mascots
are not entertaining I never watched a
mascot like oh that was kind of funny or
cute it's insulting and it's really it's
not I would say the the Philly freak the
San Diego chicken there's a couple of
classic ones where they were actually
funny that's about it
are we still bad for the like when they
slide when they run in they take the big
slide oh yeah a little guy couldn't do
it no I like when like the Philly freak
will walk up and [ __ ] with the umpires
and mess with people on the other team
and stuff like it's it's like that's one
of the classic ones but I forget the Red
Sox they tried to have on a long time
ago was called the Fenway freak and he
lasted like seven games
people would just about it holding him
with [ __ ] they always liked the 70s this
is when you could actually go there and
be a [ __ ] alcoholic scaring children
and then they brought this guy out in a
[ __ ] you know Muppet outfit that's
got the Philly freak but now they have
this the Green Monster one
yeah it's called Wally Wally right oh
it's like a pun it's a mascot with a pun
name
yeah pun for what the park is known for
yeah and then then yeah then they swing
Sweet Caroline during the seventh-inning
stretch just when I thought your YMCA
horseshit at the Yankees game trust me
it's bad but at least the you know is
the grounds crew that kind of looked
like all right like they took this
boring thing and made it entertaining a
little bit like that was kind of
interesting to watch people still spell
out YMCA was just that that's that was
always tough to watch yeah I don't need
to watch the grounds crew singing what
was probably
the gay anthem 419 for the 70s I don't
need to see them [ __ ] singing that
every seventh inning yeah that might
have been the like like they were so gay
than the [ __ ] that they were doing I
think would actually be offensive to gay
people I'm a construction worker and I
have a big mustache and I'm the leather
guy who be like there's like literally
now gay groups would be like you know
you're perpetuating stereotypes we go to
work ins grey suits just like you do or
whatever but that's [ __ ] hilarious
do you member Victor Willis the leads
say did you know they were I didn't know
they were gay I was a big villain my
father took me to see them when I was a
kid it was them in Sister Sledge was the
opening band and I didn't know legendary
you know disco showed absolutely that
was like that my teeth it was either
them or kiss was the first one and I
didn't know they were gay but I found
out like I didn't know what the village
was a Greenwich Village thing I had no
idea what any of that meant I didn't
either I thought it was cool the way oh
that's the construction worker guy quasi
construction worker
yeah I didn't know they're musicians
yeah why is he just a bass player or the
Indian Phillippi rose he still he's only
still my favorite I thought he was
awesome I love this headdress I really
did I actually like the one who looked
like something who hit on Al Pacino and
cruising Oh Glen Glen was the one I like
I thought he was badass like yeah that's
why I never saw Rob Halford from a
million miles away cuz I'm part of that
last generation way if you wore a bunch
of leather and had a mustache you would
like some badass yeah cycle I didn't
understand that there was a whole other
side to that I had no idea but now you
look back on old Halford video I'll go
back on YouTube and watch old Judas
Priest from like from that there was
that concert they didn't like 83 in
Philly there was that there was that jet
live eight or whatever it was you watch
priests from that you're like oh how did
we not know it's so obvious and I love
the fact that he came out nobody gives a
[ __ ] it's just Halford you know he's
like a big power top you know he just
he's a [ __ ] ramrod I just love the
guy nobody gives a [ __ ]
I think he grew into that role he looked
like a bottom early on I think as he got
older you know he got a little more
comfortable with himself there's a story
that he is a big dick he put some guy in
the hospital Florence he told me a story
if you put a guy on if you put any
person in the hospital with your dick
you're a legend and I heard that there
was some some hairdresser
who for years wanted Halford to fight it
it's consensual
let's put that out
clip kitchen and they're over ATM yeah
I'm talking you know the asterisk is
that it's an adult in a consensual
relationship or consensual encounter and
you willingly allow him to put your dick
and your line up in the hospital
that guy's a legend I'm just picturing
the interview afterwards with the [ __ ]
another person at what moment did you
realize you were in over your head yeah
when I was when I when I told him he has
to pull it out and I realized there was
still four more inches to go yeah there
was some one where he realized this was
a bad decision but I heard he was
bugging Halford to [ __ ] him and he was a
hairdresser or whatever he was he was
whoever the guy is that Halford oh [ __ ]
intent to the hospital and Halford
finally did it and he the guy oh you
hate [ __ ] him alright fine I'll give
you the rockstar dick yeah I hear he's
packing like an animal so there's
nothing but good good thing you think he
did it right before a show so he's
wearing all that [ __ ] awful studded
[ __ ] just the sound of your screaming in
his [ __ ] milky thighs rubber leather
pants I'm sorry everybody sorry to paint
that visual he smells good too I
interviewed him before a show on time me
and this guy Troy from the show went to
the I guess there's a garden or wherever
they were they mentally he smells so
[ __ ] good so I bought the same
cologne a lot of times I'll smell
Cologne that British rock stars have on
and I'll buy it and it's very specific
it never because they submit gay British
rock stars are just British rock stars
no Aziz not gay Aziz Aziz the
best-smelling guy in music cause he
smells better than anybody Rob Halford
smells great I wouldn't never guess that
with Aussie ass I'm not saying that you
know just you wouldn't think that he
smelled you wouldn't you wouldn't
associate him with like a really rich
guys smell but Ozzy you can smell from
down the hall and he has it I think in
his hair or whatever it's this British
Cologne and he [ __ ] he smells [ __ ]
amazing
he smells amazing Halford also smelled
good but it never smells good on me i
buy it and i just smell like garbage how
do you know I can I smell it on myself
I'm like it stinks
I thought you can't really smell
yourself oh you the Cologne you can't I
put it on and it's great for a minute
and I probably know like sure I'm like
look you suck that isn't yeah but that's
self-hatred no but I don't never get
compliments on it no one's ever said hey
you smell great now like you know when
Ozzy walks you people you [ __ ] smell
that's the first thing I noticed about
first time I met him was with jim
Florentine in 97 and the first thing
that struck me is this guy smells
amazing did not get enough ass
you know I mean they got a shell like
Jesus Christ that's where you gotta
[ __ ] send your wife into the next
room yeah go get some help you hose that
[ __ ] off of you police I can still be
married at the end of this how funny is
that he just you know he had the whole
thing with shower we got caught having
the affair and he's not I love that the
damage control
Ozzie does in an interview he's like
well I'm a [ __ ] I'm in a [ __ ] band
aren't I
like that's his reasoning like what do
you expect I thought that was the
greatest yet something you say to your
friends though you don't say that in an
interview after planning my [ __ ] said
that I am too far if it doesn't get him
divorced I'm happy he said it look I
[ __ ] the amount of [ __ ] people
that aren't in his position that can
easily sit back you know your [ __ ]
life is if you're not in a band you
don't have all these women [ __ ]
throwing themselves out here like what
the [ __ ] is he supposed to do I know I
know I'm away but you had to used you
you're like a grounded guy like I really
mean that
like I look at you you're married you
have a baby and like you you're I
[ __ ] bows Jim that's what he's a lady
in a green room until everybody leaves
and I booze dearly yeah I admire I sit
there and I just tell stories with
people they bring a bottle in and I'm
with like four or five other but I did
it the last night I was just an uh where
the [ __ ] was I stand up live in Phoenix
and they brought it they had this bottle
for us and for three days we just would
you know taking a third a third and a
third and by last night you know we just
sitting in there I go to cigar bars
I just basically oh but dude I always
used to look like [ __ ] Ralph Malph
too so it was never really a problem you
know what I mean I wasn't like a [ __ ]
like Geraldo rest his soul I mean that
guy was like a [ __ ] great-looking
those those guys you feel funny and he
had a he had like a I always had like a
really you know angry [ __ ] energy so
like most women who had even remotely
had a decent father or maybe an uncle
that they spoke to had a nice
conversation once would be running for
the hills and I would get these absolute
[ __ ] lunatics that would come up to
me and you know so it kind of took care
of itself to be honest with you it is
scary when you meet women and like the
girls you dated first or for a while
when you realize I represent something
to her like I'm an average-looking god
and there's some girls I've dated who
were better a lot better looking than I
deserved and I knew that they were
mental things I'm like I represent
something weird to her to father
mouth full of shame I would say that you
know yeah it's monster rain I mean the
names of yours very uh yeah you've
carved out quite a niche for yeah you
know I got I figure I gotta be honest
cuz I what type of girl tried to
blackmail me I hate to go trying to
blackmail me one time she had no idea
who I was and we had hooked up a few
times it was a money thing not a big
expect X a lot of dirty fantasies and
then she wanted me to send her money to
try blackmail me and I'm like well I'll
send you money to help you with this but
I'm not doing it that and and she was
well maybe all your friends would want
to see your fantasies played out on
Facebook and I'm like you really don't
know who you're talking to texture I
don't give a [ __ ] everybody who I know
knows what I'm like and what I do at
that moment I was grateful to be me yeah
you gotta be you know what when you put
it all out there and you know they can't
catch there's nothing funny one of the
fun I wish that was a scene in a movie
watching somebody thinking that they can
blackmail somebody and they just
completely don't give a [ __ ] do that I'm
not gonna say the guy's name but that
happened to a hockey player he was like
in his 40s and he oh yes yeah he hooked
up with some like 19 years legal and
everything and she's just like I'm gonna
tweet this out you know if you don't
blah blah blah he goes what then I slept
with a smoking hot chick half my age he
goes get and do it I don't give a [ __ ]
yeah and she did sometimes they will
they will at times do it she said she
was gonna he said he didn't care she did
and he didn't give a [ __ ] nobody else
did oh my god
this guy did something legal yeah she
really not like a leg just yeah he did
what we'd all love to do shame on him
good for him but if you're married if
you got kid you there's so many guys
that they like I heard a lot of rappers
get like girls well you know special
ladies a lot of rappers you know or a
little on the DL as they say about
certain things and they get blackmailed
a lot like I've heard a lot a lot of
times the girls will go yeah I want
$30,000 I'm gonna start [ __ ]
screaming in the lobby and there's been
times of that stuff has worked it's a
shame Jesus you can't just go go ahead
go screaming the lobby stupid well you
know what if everyone was like me you
could and you like I wouldn't I wouldn't
give a [ __ ] I would like that's what
kills me like whenever a controversy
like that comes out like I like you
talking about that guy with the massage
therapist and all that stuff I always
just think like I can that
can wait to go to his next movie just to
make this type of [ __ ] go away cried to
support it yeah because even the worst
case scenario is they did something
where they just [ __ ] up they [ __ ] up
well you've seen the guy goes on the
road he bangs you know [ __ ] around and
his wife I mean that's between them
yeah does that mean I don't like that
song any better yeah those [ __ ]
people who do that [ __ ] well they just
go like oh [ __ ] that guy I'm done with
this movie really get done with those
movies I'm done with this movies when
his movies suck you know if he's if he's
not out there you know those same
[ __ ] people will still go to Mass
every Sunday the Catholic Church right
you know wasn't everybody it's like is
that really what you're thinking that's
just your fear of dying and not knowing
where you go when you die and you don't
want to piss off the invisible guy all
right my buddy my brother said it the
best he goes talk about the Catholic
Church he goes dude if that was any
other [ __ ] business they would be
shut down [ __ ] shut down I'm still
odd and I think of this all but the fact
that you don't believe in name-calling
I've thought of that a lot like how
negative it is and bad it is and it's
something not that I've had cause to cuz
I'm single at this point but we're in a
relationship with the woman I've never
done you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] implying
like I would never have thought and but
I hearing you say that is that yeah I
guess it really is a damaging thing you
can't do it I can't because it builds up
it builds up resentment because people
don't forget like I got this weird thing
if my wife dies you know you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I don't care I know
other guys that would be like you know
you like that really would actually it
would hurt him in a way that they would
as a man they wouldn't want to admit I
don't give a [ __ ] but like I I saw
enough guys growing up doing that you
[ __ ] [ __ ] thing and everything like
that and I just I just I saw what that
did I was a little kid and just saw and
I just saw it it just it didn't look you
know this big deep voice yelling it you
know right it just was not it just I I
don't know so I just made a vow is just
one of those things I was like you know
what I'm not doing that but then there
was other stupid behavior that I guess I
didn't recognize them then I repeated
that but that was the one that that I I
didn't do so what'd he do she called you
[ __ ] you just talking about what
she's doing is if I go all real but she
I wish presence of mind I sigh what what
do I do
you know I definitely say the F word a
lot but I don't you know well now that I
have a daughter so I really I just
should I don't do that I'm not gonna
[ __ ] sit there and scream and yeah
when there's a baby in the room doesn't
really change that we could Sam my radio
partner just had a baby and it's a
everybody I know is having kids I guess
it changes the way you do [ __ ] right
yeah because there's that whole I think
for the first time in your life you're
actually aware of your behavior
affecting other people right
with you know with your girlfriend or
your wife it's an adult to adult things
so you really don't you're like oh this
person is an adult they can drive a car
you know I can say this stuff this isn't
gonna affect them you know but it's when
you have the kid and everything and it's
just like you know that this could
actually affect who they marry right oh
yeah this guy like that literally you
know if I do what I'm you know if I flip
out right now and I consistently do this
this could literally drive my daughter
to a trailer park someday right you know
and and be one thing if I was just
completely oblivious then I could just
sit at a bar go now she's a [ __ ]
loser
yeah oh she grew up in a house now she's
into thing but I'm kinda where of the
effect of it now and then I would have
to sit there and take on that kind of
guilt so plus I don't know I I don't um
I just growing up there was a lot of
just the the era when I grew up like
every authority Authority person was
just so not approachable and as I said
this and this is what it is and you shut
the [ __ ] up and it was that just you
know that's kind of what stoked the
whole fire in me I think so I try to uh
you know I think you go one of two ways
you either repeat it or you just
remember that so like um I actually got
a really good compliment from sell me
one time said you know you guys might be
she got to come by come by my house he
goes my kids love you and I was like
really he goes yeah he goes Abele you
talk to him like they're adults I wasn't
even aware I was doing it like I would
be talking to like his uh ten year old
right what Grady you and I you getting
homework now that sucked I hated that
like I wasn't thinking that I was and
they kind of liked it that they were
talking to adult like oh this is this is
somebody older who they think knows
everything he's saying
how he hated it kind of gave making
admitted okay to be like oh this sucks
man I hope that didn't make him not do
their [ __ ] homework yeah but I would
just you know I would address it rather
than being like no you need to sit down
you need to learn that this is what life
is it's sitting there doing [ __ ] you
don't want to do like that's so much
that you learn that that you like you
don't think that you can actually go out
and achieve [ __ ] and like life becomes
like [ __ ] when is this over just staring
at a clock and people saying that I
think have the tires don't even mean it
they just think it's [ __ ] an adult is
supposed to stay like to say like you
know what I mean [ __ ] are you buckled
down you do you if I said that to
anybody I would entirely be going shut
up you don't [ __ ] believe that
I cannot wait to tell my daughter I
don't know I cannot wait to tell it why
is this bla bla bla and I don't know why
be like well you know cuz I don't read
you I don't cuz it makes me sleepy I'm
just gonna [ __ ] honesty up to it there's
a lot of stuff your dad isn't good at
sweetheart you want some ice cream
yeah did you want I I'm in the middle I
can you know I'm gonna point where I'm
48 no wife no girlfriend like I you know
I don't know I'm if I'm the best
boyfriend candidate but I'm tired of
being single like I'm kind of oh there
you go that's where I think of it you
got sick of it right yeah I got uh no
you know idea was I finally I just
looked at like what I was doing and then
you know we have to like I said joke
about that on stage that's like the 90th
[ __ ] person that doesn't go well and
there's only so long even dude you took
two [ __ ] psychos yeah after a while
it's like what am i doing did I chase
him away in tech I've had some updated
literally four I lose people in text
message I'm so I'm so like I want to
either talk dirty or I just I just want
to keep pushing the envelope and the
next thing you know they stop talking to
me so I know I'm doing something wrong
it's not them then him don't talk it
over
I'm just creeping them out on some level
I don't know why that just reminded me
this last night I was watching uh what
is that [ __ ] show with Andy Cohen
when he does the wrap ups of the the
Real Housewives oh not his talk shows
look what happens live yes that show oh
that one so my wife always watches that
show that's one of those crossover shows
I have to watch with her so we don't
battle over the team right right so I'm
watching it was Jennifer Lopez and
oh Jesus Christ just went blank ins ray
liotta dude Ray Liotta was [ __ ]
hilarious he just answers it doesn't
give a [ __ ] no he doesn't he just
answered everything straight up straight
up they were like what
so for cocaine like in Goodfellas like
what are they using he was like cocaine
would be like who's the most they play
this thing you can plead the fifth and
oh yeah they'd never be never pleaded
the fifth would ask him they asked him
like oh you who's the worst kisser of
anybody easy you've been with this
person before his person and you know
and he's doing all the things so who was
the worst kisser like this was gonna be
the thing goes uh I don't think I kissed
any of them and he goes well then who
would you guess and he goes out
Sigourney Weaver just said it they go
who's the worst actor most overrated
actor than 90s and he was most overrated
he goes fan I'd probably say Clint
Eastwood and then somebody mumbled blah
blah blah blah blah was showed he turns
around he goes I don't give a [ __ ] he is
kind of untouchable at this point he is
Ray Liotta he gets you know no but it
was real it was yeah oh yeah I'm going
to be dangerous he literally goes I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm Ray
Liotta and by the way I who I am I don't
give a [ __ ] what a brilliant game that
is plead the fifth on one of these three
questions then what'd it do it was then
it would then passes it over to you and
then you got a you know and it's all
this this you know he did all these
squirming questions like he was absent
like Jennifer Lopez okay when you you
know I mean - you've been proposed to
five times did you who did you say no -
and she's a nice person doesn't want to
say it and Ray Liotta was just sitting
there go and just plead the fifth
I'll answer something like he just
completely didn't give a [ __ ] oh do is
you're two of them together yeah cuz
they're on that cops show together oh
you know it's funny I auditioned for
that I did Doug Davidoff got the part
and he I think he's better for that than
I am anyway not just acting ability but
you know he looked more of the part of a
kind of a slick like internal affairs
guy if that's why I didn't know that was
on that yeah yeah he's got a good part
he brought Ray Liotta into the Comedy
Cellar one night Tom but you know I'm
not gonna get it I'd rather see somebody
I like get it
that's great it brings in a glimpse of
what your life would have been yeah cool
hangin Raley oh that would have been fun
that would have been kind of nice
Jim you're next what should they say
about you yeah sorry it was my bad sto
Mike Mike Mike she announces you before
you go on no I understand you're saying
Oh
as bad as that joke was everybody Jim
Norton special is gonna be the opposite
of that mouth full of shame
it's so stupid to keep going back to
this when people listen to a podcast
it's like there's no just no they're
right there's no commercials coming in
but I just feel like I have to keep
going back to March 14th in case you
forget because then they gotta rewind
and try to remember where and way of
course we're probably tweeted out I did
love Netflix - I've never done anything
with them before I know you've done a
bunch of stuff with them they're so easy
they're like alright just put it
together and they Robbie it a couple of
minor suggestions they don't overly
manage you it was a [ __ ] great it was
so nice to do it and I'm actually happy
with it like you don't you shoot
something this one I actually feel it's
it's dirtier than I kind of intended and
wait the next time you go to Australia
now that it's on Netflix like you'll
sell tickets should hope so
I'm going to you I told you you inspire
me completely to do I'm only doing this
stuff because you got in my head and I
hear Bill burn my [ __ ] head all the
time going what are you waiting for to
do it I really do it's like but you were
right yeah watch all stop selling
tickets I'll be like you watching
Davidoff coming in with watchin you sell
it out the [ __ ] what is that thing in
Sydney the Opera House and I'll be like
I used to do that I die you know it's
fine I did one show there it was a TV
tape no was it was TV taping and
something else and I enjoyed city
melbourne was good but Sydney was really
good and I might like Melbourne a little
bit better you did yeah I got an Perth
was fun cuz I landed there was Australia
Day and everybody was just [ __ ]
getting hammered and [ __ ] so I was like
yeah this this country's I didn't go to
Perth I didn't go was your first time
Fiona's Grand in Perth is the Bon Scott
Oh buried there they got the stash yeah
we did it we went to the Bon Scott wall
in Melbourne it was like in one of the
things someone painted a tribute wall to
Bon Scott you know it's Bon Scott
because it says ac/dc
but if it didn't you'd be like you know
or as they say a kodaka down there
why oh do they really yeah and then what
is what his burger can call down there I
don't remember
[ __ ] Royale with cheese ya know it's
something my friends know cuz somebody
down there actually had already had a
Burger King and he sued the corporation
and they what the [ __ ] is that you're
looking it up Jonathan did you sell
tickets when you first went through the
first time no you know I think I did the
first time I went out there was like an
O four and I did something for Comedy
Central and we flew in from from you
know New York so it was like six hours
to five and a half to LA and then
layover and then 14 hours yeah and
you'll and they let you sleep a little
bit and then it's like it's already the
next day and then we taped it and then
the next day he's supposed to go back
was so [ __ ] nuts so I was just like
oh [ __ ] that I'm gonna stay here for a
few days Hungry Jack's that's right
Hungry Jack's okay that means nothing to
anybody listening to this but I thought
it was cool and I just hung out there
and I bought all these ac/dc albums on
CD that they're the original like like
it was TNT ace know the names it's like
TNT was the original album that then
became high voltage but their version
had like dirty deeds on it which later
became its own album you name an EP over
here so we went you know I bought like
all these you know cuz I got a big
family so I just bought it for my
brothers and sisters and oh that's cool
yeah
and drove around saw the Apostles and
just driving on the other side of the
road was really [ __ ] up
and any time I went to take a turn like
the joke was I would just pretend that I
wanted to kill myself
and then I would actually make the right
decision because everything else it
doesn't even make sense you like what
the [ __ ] just makes no sense especially
when you're when you make a right turn
and you're sitting you're sitting on the
passenger's side and you got to go wide
you're like what the [ __ ] you just
picture like a semi but late at night
when I came out I you know where the
[ __ ] I was at I was with this other
comic one of those comics I do was from
like Scotland or some [ __ ] an expatriate
I just met him and I never saw him again
but uh we got on the road with no
streetlights and drove probably maybe
eight nine hundred feet and the same
time we both went like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
and got over but there was nobody coming
we're definitely starting to go up a
hill so yeah I'm sure people get
our service when you're out there Jimmy
that's what I'm trying I we oh bird when
I was there I mean Olbers there it was
great but I'm also going to Norway and I
think I'm doing something Scandinavian
I've never been to any of these places
I'm doing all of them that whole run
through Oslo Helsinki yeah Stockholm
dude yeah it's the best but they say
those are just places that you know as
an American to actually go there I mean
I think you got to be like you're either
in the Illuminati or you're like a
downhill ski or some [ __ ] because other
than that you're not gonna go there
it's far it's just not on our radar to
go there I have beautiful countries and
the people of the people are great do
you fly in and out the state can I I
have sleep apnea and I [ __ ] I take
Dramamine to fly like I came this
morning from Portland so I'm like I'm
very loopy and I'm tired and you just do
a show that night and then fly out the
next morning I kid there was a panicking
about that what I do is I turn it into
like a paid vacation so what I do is I
fly over there and I either do the tour
and then I meet my wife afterwards or
other times I've done it like just
because of our schedules that work out
like all right let's do the vacation
first and then not only will I be rested
I'll be you know yeah talking about to
acclimated yeah time and that type of
thing so I've done both but uh you know
there's all you know I build a little a
build wash it around sporting events and
stuff like you know what I wanted to go
to this year I I don't think it's gonna
work out though but I was gonna go to
that there's this motorcycle race on the
Isle of Man which is an island between
Britain and Ireland home saying that
right of [ __ ] Wales whatever the [ __ ]
you want to call it um and it's just
this [ __ ] motorcycle race that's just
like it I mean more people have died
than years they've had it it's just
really dude they go on like [ __ ] 200
miles an hour down these country roads
and [ __ ] and they go come blazing
through town I mean it's like if if you
love the beginning of the last Mad Max
this is like the closest you're gonna
see to the real version of it I mean it
dude these guys are [ __ ] lunatics
like they know they going so fast and
that digs little ass country roads and
there's like stone walls and [ __ ] and
trees like you're dead and pedestrians
are getting killed once in a while - I'm
surprised that so many people stand so
close that my only nervousness about it
is
how can I get high up enough to see a
little bit more of it right because I'm
worried that it's just gonna be like you
know I'm gonna stand a couple I halfway
around the world you see he like and
then stand there for like another
[ __ ] twenty minutes because they go
by that [ __ ] friend and that's it
yeah I went to the Daytona 500 we were
on the in the infield on like this
little building so I could actually
stand and kind of watch him go all the
way around but like if you just stand
the first time once in the Indy 500
I was just you're just in a corner and
it just becomes this drinking game and
everybody's bet on like four different
cars and you just pray to God there's
gonna be an accident or some [ __ ] in
front of you right just something
interesting
yeah and it's actually really amazing
the first time you see and you actually
hear this tires skid like a real
accident you're like oh yeah I guess it
is a car for some reason I never thought
it would sound like that but the thing
is it going so fast as they'll hit the
wall in front of you and then the debris
just they fly down are you seeing the
accidents yeah I saw a guy hit a wall
and for me one time but it's like it's
he hits it in front of you and by the
time your brain reacts to what that is
it's he's already a quarter-mile away
it's like they hit it let me stop do you
watch like boxing and MMA cuz you use
such a sports car do you watch a combat
sports or no yeah I keep going in and
out of MMA it's like depends on my road
schedule where it's like you know I work
a lot on Saturday night right and if a
couple months goes by and I keep missing
the fights I hate it but it's a big
thing that me and my wife do like she
[ __ ] loves it
does she like UFC dude she oh she's
almost embarrassing like she gets up and
yells at the TV oh great she totally
gets into it when Anderson Silva like
had the compound fracture of his leg I
was like oh my god looking away and she
has this weird thing where maybe she
should have got in the medical field
because she was wasn't like she was
happy it happened she was just more
fascinated by what it looked like it's
just like good lord oh yeah I always co
that's like the when they break that
[ __ ] thing that's like you ever see
like a little kid put on like his dad's
rain boot jumps on the side and just
folds up like I can't I cannot look it I
was at that fight that was their second
fight that was nobody knew what happened
like until the replay you just saw him
fall and then the replay played the
whole place that was a horrible but he's
still kicking
he's still using that leg he's I heard
when you break the bone though doesn't
come back
stronger some reason they might have
strengthened it with metal I heard it
was a pretty clean break here we go
we're going into the abyssal you know
does it make it stronger
you heard they did metal yeah we don't
know but he's able to fight with it
let's just give answers jump yeah why it
happened
I remember overhearing somebody say that
and I never did any background check on
them and have you ever gone to one of
the fights yes yes I did what is that oh
is that the picture of him going by on
the stretcher Jesus Christ Jim you look
like you're in a [ __ ] band dude I
gotta tell you this guy took this weight
off what two three years ago and you've
kept it off what are you doing it and I
just just eating in the gym just that
that really is it but when did you
finally cuz you you were you were on
those up and awful just that moment of
clarity oh just so much [ __ ] selfish
what were you eating and where were you
when you when you finally were just like
I can't do this anymore you know I
really don't remember I what I do
remembers is going to the gym and going
I am going to go I was [ __ ] I was
just sick of like when you feel it in
your back above your belt that little
bit of [ __ ] fat it's just soft like a
little lamb I started getting the the
effort noises putting on socks I was
just like oh god I'm becoming that guy
so I just like this last trip I just had
I got off the road two days ago now I've
just been it's so funny I literally just
two days of not eating Burger King or
Steak and Shake and I never I just kind
of fell into this I think was just
because of the lack of sleep I've been
getting and just going on on the road
and then having to do the shows and the
pressure putting them together in a new
hour I just been under a lot of stress
that I've just been like last second
I'll [ __ ] I'm hungry let's go here I
don't give a [ __ ] just stuff this in me
and fill up the hole and it just was
yeah la is dangerous for me because I go
this is this what a [ __ ] fruit I'm
turning into Jonathan and I would love
it it is a great [ __ ] fruit weed I
like eating sushi here but then we go to
the yogurt stop on Santa Monica beliefs
in the world is the [ __ ] yogurt stop
I'm Santa Monica I love where is it it's
on Santa Monica by rage
let's talk just talking to Jonathan for
got put on put on the [ __ ] head yeah
you just speaking to Jonathan brainstein
everybody no hello yeah Jonathan who's
very instrumental when we first started
doing the Patrice O'Neal benefit that's
right please help me get in touch with
all the guys and everything like that
and it's an amazing thing that's still
going on it's incredible oh yeah just
let us know how much if no no no it's
Maureen Tarrant Maureen Taryn deals with
all the infrastructure and the heard of
a DD that is booking a bunch of
comedians dude it's like literally it's
like you got 12 cows just [ __ ] or I
guess what what runs cows don't run you
got ten bowls you got ten [ __ ] things
that run their own a different direction
things that run all going in different
directions go
but February 21st that normally when it
is right yes kinda we kind of know it's
gonna be in February now yeah now she
lets us know in enough advance that's
why we do a Tuesday cuz sometimes fans
goes why the [ __ ] is this on a Tuesday
night it's because cuz guys are working
for free and this is what that's the day
comedians are are in town so next year I
already know like one of the guys out
here every year we try to like maybe fly
somebody in and we got an idea of
possibly who we're gonna try to use this
next year but it's been a great thing
cuz it I just hate like you know like
when someone passes away like with
unfortunately we're at that age you know
and we're you had that one-time benefit
you're like okay here's your sack of
cash good luck for the next 40 years and
it's you know he was taking care of
those people so it's it's definitely
been a great thing so but and the thing
about here's the bean I think it is to
this year is that it's the fifth annual
one I have officially done this four
more times than Patrice would have done
it for me I think might have been this
year I thought was the perfect
combination of a great mix of people the
ball breaking was on a whole other
[ __ ] level and then when Leslie Jones
told that Patrice story oh my god it was
just [ __ ] no dude this [ __ ] that you
said when both - Keith Keith Robinson
Keith Roberts Keith unfortunately
suffered a mild stroke was a moment
coming up on two years ago no I say
listen yeah you're on it
and he said of course now he's doing
like somebody's funniest [ __ ] or
whatever so Jim when he out rode him he
goes
keep going for Keith Robinson he
should've had a stroke 15 years ago the
place [ __ ] dies laughing and then
your other one was like well it's funny
is even after a stroke Keith is easier
to understand than rich Bob yeah how how
you followed it with the rusty of jokes
but people like yeah people like the
attacks on each other that that's always
a crowd favorite
you had one where you said I think Colin
came after you and you said ah he's here
he's has to be back at Men's Wearhouse
soon he was wearing a suit that night
and it was what boss is awful hat this
year huh and Pete Davidson kept telling
him the truth going to looks awful and
like Pete that's not how this game works
yeah yeah tell him it looks good you
wait till he goes out on stage yeah you
don't try to discourage him you wait
until he's on and then you [ __ ]
attack him in front of the entire
theater Seamus it was another another
one that's the first time we had him and
he came out he was thrashing fauces had
I think they actually make in front of
us is the old guys I yeah I think that
but then Voss leveled him walk his
peepee talks about his dad dying on an
11 and voice said the one good thing is
that
Pete that I didn't have to see him in
that blouse and he said he would have
thrown himself in another fire sweater
he had artsy Golden Girls sweater yeah
one could wear yeah that was really bad
it was really really shitty I wanted to
make fun of it but I knew I didn't like
it I'm like you're on a TV show if
you're [ __ ] good-looking young guy
and if you dress slightly effeminate
it's like you're not getting enough
[ __ ] so I knew that that's why I was
gonna come out I was like I can't come
out you know the in potential yeah I I
knew that I was just an old man getting
jealous you know now I had to Rosa just
showed up in that than I would have I
mean the sweater art by itself should
have been burned it was brutal it was it
was bad but you know you knew the
reasons for attacking it would have been
more yeah it's one of those [ __ ] guys
remember those those all those people
that Madonna used to [ __ ] in Soho in New
York City those Benitez those artists
yeah he looked like he [ __ ] when he
dies his artwork it was going to be
worth something
yeah like a young I can I've never
Basquiat yeah
I've aged that's one thing you know yeah
I don't like any of those guys because
it always makes me feel foolish because
everybody looks at this [ __ ] like it's
[ __ ] amazing and like one of the I
don't know like the two lays one I
always know that I'm a dope was when I
try to read out loud bat and when I go
to a museum because I mean you want to
just talk about flatlining emotionally
and it just it means not dude I went
when I went to Paris I went into the
Louvre
I could not get out of there fast enough
I was like literally almost shouting at
people like where is it where is the
[ __ ] where's the Mona Lisa so I can
look at it and get the [ __ ] out of you
and you get out of it and there's all
these people just you know just creating
like a ledge with their other hand and
then [ __ ] holding their chin with the
other one and I was just I just sort of
I peered over like it was the
presidential motorcade driving by a
quick look that was it did it move you
didn't give a [ __ ] the only thing it was
cools it's been recreated so many times
to be like that's the actual one that's
it yeah and dude I saw the Sistine
Chapel I couldn't be not [ __ ] small
it was I think the guy was dogging it I
mean it's saying it took him that
[ __ ] long walk in I literally was
like this is it and some way shape or
inspiring that they recently dug up
Christ's tomb in the church and they had
to do some anything they know where he's
buried huh
they know where they're supposed to move
Christ they do know yes [ __ ] Al
Capone's vault it probably is the Shroud
of Turin it probably is [ __ ] but I
mean it is in in Catholicism they do
kind of Revere it somewhere and you know
Jerusalem I guess but these guys had to
go down and they were doing some kind of
maintenance work on it to which they had
to be done on the lid over the tomb I'm
like that would probably get me like
look this is a pretty important place
but the art museums do nothing for me I
did see the Washington Crossing the
Delaware painting it's [ __ ] massive
it's probably the size of this room in
the Metropolitan Izumo that was kinda or
is it then well I would rather look at
that [ __ ] than something like abstract
yeah me too that looked like you've
rolled a baby and paint and just [ __ ]
through it yeah yeah and this I like the
real event I went to the van Gogh one
one where where the [ __ ] whatever
country that's in I want
that and I actually liked that one it's
not cuz he's a fellow [ __ ] redhead it
was just I like that it likes with
Netherlands yeah how about I like a
Norman Rockwell are you sure it's not in
Denmark I thought maybe it could be the
whole way you dressed me but I know I
know you I know that you're right he has
the initials on his shirt he gives like
the air of authority but half of times
he knows we're talking about half the
times he does
oh this is that way you have your
initials right there yeah that's very
unique
yeah the tailor this is that near your
your pancreas is that why you put it
there
I thought you did it on the cuff link on
the cuff yeah there's two styles you can
do it the cuffs you can do it here what
is it and what is that style I don't
know I've always had it here though so I
don't know yeah the tailor that I got
this made yet he did gentleman seen it
John is a true gentleman yeah the trying
to tell how difficult you are as a
client cuz I know when you're not around
his shirt is untucked yeah he's got a
little rock'n'roll compound there's
chicks to talk to to the Greek alright
we're coming up on an hour here Jim I'm
sorry you know I'm such a [ __ ] huge
fan you and I always tell you this dude
I owe so much of the tickets that I sell
to on the road that you were generous
when you got a lot of guys would have
got that Opie and Anthony gig and they
would have kept the [ __ ] door closed
and you let us all run in so I want to
thank you please dude you know see I'm
blowing all my money on Foot Locker
t-shirts here no but you do it well
deservedly like your great comic and I
mean it's like yeah I stopped my
compliment with a compliment you son no
but it's it's it is nice to see like
mouth full of shame I've gone Netflix
March 14th I love you to death Jimmy all
the success in the world to you I will
definitely be tweeting this out if you
want to talk to Jimmy Norton you can get
him on Twitter at Jim Norton Instagram
at Jim Norton Facebook just type in Jim
Norton and Jim Norton calm and you can
hear me in Sam in the morning I have to
plug my M Roberts we are now doing the
show together Monday through Friday 8 to
11 on channel 103 I have satellite radio
now and I'd look at the listen you guys
all the time it's great it's really
finally get caught up oh I can't believe
how long I did satellite radio before I
got it
it's [ __ ] tremendous you just got it
I just got it I never had it in my car
and I finally just said I finally never
bought myself a nice car
one of those frugal [ __ ] douche bags
so I finally just said I'm buying a nice
car did you have the lanai yeah I was
just like whatever they said you want
this I was like yes if you want that yes
treating yourself climate control yes I
just said yes to everything that's why I
get shitty gas miles you're so [ __ ]
heavy with all the options that I have
mean that I'm sorry I was late - oh you
weren't late Jimmy pretty sure you a
building anticipation
I'll see you guys